[Applause]
i'm happy to have found someone else
who's laughing about death because
i have been laughing about it my whole
life and the looks i've gotten
the rooms i've shut down the awkward
situations i've created
with laughing at death and i'm laughing
at it because it terrifies me the most
and the one thing that's all waiting for
us
you can't laugh at yeah i think it's the
most important things you need to laugh
at
even if you're at a funeral maybe don't
like during the eulogy laugh
but you know go to the bathroom it's
okay i think it's the best medicine
see i don't want a funeral i want to
party there will be no sadness i want
people to like
rave i don't want like tea i'm available
for this funeral if you're
hiring someone
good i really want people to like look
forward to it and be like that was the
best time i've ever
oh god don't worry we got it under
control not for many many many years
robin i guarantee that if you have
anything to do with my funeral it's
going to be the exact kind that i am
looking for
and this is so dark james i gotta go
i was like i got an image to keep up
here ladies and gentlemen
you forget the funeral we'll do i'll do
your birthday party yeah well
let's not wait robin why did you get
into comedy like
other than being an inherently funny
person with a great outlook was
what was the catalyst um well i mean
kind of what we're saying my childhood
was very difficult in the sense
i have a bone disease so i wore leg
braces as a kid i had
a lot of a lot of surgeries it was just
a really difficult
time and comedy was my escape
i'd watch sitcoms and daytime talk show
this
what we're doing right now i was a
little kid just watching this
um because i didn't really go to school
much because of everything and this was
this was my medicine so i knew from six
years old i'd grow up
to try to make other people laugh so
it's kind of
fitting as far as comedy my dad who's an
accountant
was like you should try stand up i was
like you're an idiot but he was right
now oh robin and you just got like
recognized on the street right
okay someone stopped me and she's like
excuse me are you
famous and i was like i am i
am and then i was like do you want a
picture because i only think she wanted
a figure but i was so excited
so yeah it was a really big deal and
here's the thing it's like obviously
this is so
20 20 that i would go viral and everyone
has to wear a mask and no one could
recognize me
it's like obviously this would happen um
i i think that you did heal
people with this i think you did put
medicine out into the world
and i think that you two finding each
other
out there in the ether and putting this
out into the world
was the gift that everybody needed so i
just i thank you so much
jennifer do you want to say anything to
robin you i just want to say
thanks you just you made me laugh on a
really hard day
and um i just needed the whole world to
have the kind of
moment that you gave me and i didn't
know that you were a comedian
i'm so thrilled i had you know i was a
performer who struggled for
years and years and years and years and
i know that moment where you're suddenly
somebody
what you can do and like you get that
little bit of a hand
but it wouldn't have mattered if you
weren't already just
you ready and if all that work you've
been doing all this time wasn't all
leading you to where you're supposed to
go
keep living your beautiful messed up
messy
imperfect funny life
and and thank you for sharing it with us
well at robinshaw
comic is your instagram handle we'll
have it up on
all of our platforms but you will no
longer
need us soon but keep us in the club
because
we just want to celebrate funny women
doesn't everyone just need this in their
day and life so
thank you to both of you thank you for
bringing robin and me together i'm so
happy to meet you
and good luck and drew i'm so excited
for you keep just doing what you're
doing
sunshine it up girl talk to you guys
later thank you and don't forget that a
portion of this will go
to save the children so go to our
website for all that information
robin jennifer wow thank you so much
[Music]
you